[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOMINIC PREUSS: Good afternoon.
My name is Dominic Preuss.
I'm the product lead for
our database products
on Google Cloud Platform.
Welcome to Cloud Spanner 201.
Very excited to have Peter
Bakkum here from Quizlet
to also talk about his
experience with Cloud Spanner.
At the start of every
session I like to set goals.
If this isn't what
you came here for,
feel free to go to
another session.
I won't be offended.
We're going to talk about how
to set up your Cloud Spanner
schema.
We're going to talk about
how to optimize your queries.
And then we're going to
get lessons from Peter
about how to migrate
and implement
a application in Cloud Spanner.
Just a quick show of
hands, how many people
were at the Spanner 101 session?
All right.
Good.
I'll do a quick overview
of Cloud Spanner
before we dive in.
So summarizing from
the Cloud Spanner 101
and for all of those of you who
have come to the Cloud Spanner
booth, what is Cloud Spanner?
So Cloud Spanner is Google's
mission-critical scalable
relational database service.
What this means is that you
get a relational database
with ACID semantics and
transactional consistency
with horizontal scalability.
So you get the horizontal
scalability of a NoSQL system
with the transactional
semantics and sequence semantics
that you come to expect
from your traditional RDBMS.
Cloud Spanner is a fully
managed database service
with global scale, traditional
relational semantics.
So you get schemas,
ACID transactions, SQL.
We do automatic
synchronous replication
within and across regions.
And it's been battle
tested inside of Google.
In the 101 session
I went through how
our last manually restart
in MySQL took several years
and led to us to build
Cloud Spanner where it's
been in production at Google
behind most of our mission
critical applications for
the last nine plus years.
Schema design.
So one of the things that's
really interesting about Cloud
Spanner is when we did the
demo at the keynote today
and you saw the application you
don't really have many levers.
When you create a Cloud Spanner
instance you give us a name,
you tell us what
the topology is--
do you want regional and
later this year we'll have
multi-regional--
and you tell us the number
of nodes that you want.
You don't pre-provision storage.
You don't tell us
anything about your data.
You just tell us
the number of nodes.
And so 100% of your levers for
optimizing your performance
on Spanner are your
schema and your queries.
So similar to Cloud
Bigtable your schema design
is incredibly important in
determining the performance
that your application is going
to get when you deploy it.
So let's start with the basics.
So people ask me, I've
got a MySQL database,
I've got a postscript
database, how do I migrate?
So the first thing
is your schema.
Cloud Spanner supports the
most common SQL data types.
So booleans, integers, floats,
strings, bytes, arrays, dates
and timestamps.
I've put it up
against MySQL so you
can see we support all
of the similar ones
except MySQL doesn't
support arrays.
And then obviously
MySQL and postscripts
have lots of other
data types things
like JSON and other features
that we haven't implemented yet
in Cloud Spanner.
The key thing here is that
anything that you see--
anything that you have in your
MySQL or your postscript schema
should be directly transferable
into Cloud Spanner.
The first thing you have to be
very aware of in Cloud Spanner
when building your schemas
is interleave tables.
So MySQL doesn't have a
concept of child tables.
Postscripts does
have child tables,
but they're for a
different purpose.
Interleave tables in
Spanner is the way
that you can tell Cloud Spanner
the logical relationship
of your data.
And this allows us to
serve your data more
effectively and efficiently.
So the way to think
of an interleave table
is if you have a row--
in this case singers--
and all of your other
data is related to that--
in this case albums and songs--
you want them all
joined together.
So think of an interleave
table as a pre-computed
join on your data to allow your
queries to be really efficient.
What happens here is that when
we are querying your data--
so if you say give me all the
songs for a specific singer--
if you have those
interleaved then
we can very quickly
and efficiently
return those results
to you because we know
that all the data is related.
And so we'll make best
efforts to make sure
that all of that data is
located on the same node
and very physically close
to its related data.
So we can return it
as quickly as possible
and hopefully avoid
two phase commits
when we do transactions.
So by telling us that
this thing is related
to this other thing, which
we call data locality,
we can actually start
to do a much better job
of serving your data.
The other thing that's important
about interleave tables
is that Cloud Spanner does
not support the concept
of foreign key constraints.
Our version of foreign
key constraints
are these interleave tables.
So if you need cascade
on delete between items
then interleave tables is the
way that you achieve this.
So if you want to do cascade
on delete for a object
or for a row it's a
pretty good signal to you
that you should probably
interleave it with its parents.
So what does this
look like in a schema?
Again, Cloud Spanner
uses standard SQL
for schemas and for queries.
So as you're doing your
DDLs in defining your schema
this is what it would look like.
So create table singers.
I have an integer field
for the singer ID.
I've got a string for first
name, a string for last name,
and a byte field for
singer info where
the primary key is singer ID.
Now albums always
are tied to a singer
so therefore I can put a
album ID and an album title,
set the primary keys.
So on an interleave
table piled tables
have to include the
primary keys of the parent.
This is how we literally do
the physical interleaving
of the data in the database.
So my primary key has to
include singer ID because
of the parent.
And then I can say
interleave on parent singers
on delete cascade.
So this is how I implement
a foreign key constraint
in terms of cascade on delete.
But it's also how I'd
do a pre-computed join
between singers and albums.
Now to go another layer songs
always belong to an album.
So now I can say
create table songs.
We can add a track
ID and a song name.
The primary key has to include
the primary keys of the two
previous tables-- so
Singer ID and album ID--
and now we can add track
ID as a primary key.
So I interleave and paired
albums for on delete.
So as you're
building your schemas
this is how you
tell Spanner what
is the logical relationship
of your data in the schema.
I talked a little bit
about primary keys.
Spanner is different than some
of the relational databases.
We don't have
auto-increment IDs.
It's very important that we have
distribution of primary keys.
So it's very important that
you don't do sequential keys,
specifically not timestamps.
We recommend that you use real
world identifiers because this
generally gives us sufficient
amount of randomization
to shard your data
between the nodes.
And, as we talked
about before, it
defines the physical
relationship of the data.
So the primary keys
are the way that we
know that one thing
relates to another.
The next concept that every good
RDBMS has is secondary indexes.
So I built my schema,
I've run some queries,
and I see that they're slow.
How can I speed
up those queries?
One way that I can speed up
a query is by adding indexes.
So Spanner allows you to
build secondary indexes.
So in this case
we've got a table
that has marketing budget,
which is an integer.
We've defined the primary
keys in the parent table.
And now we've added
a function in our DDL
that says create index albums
by album title on albums
where the key is album title.
So this allows us to-- or
on the column album title.
So what it does is it allows
us to more efficiently query
the table albums
without having to do
a table scan of the
entire primary table.
Pretty straightforward.
Interleave indexes allow
you to co-locate your index
with your data.
So again, if you are
always doing queries inside
of a certain key space--
so in this particular time
if you're always searching for
all the things for a singer--
I want to know every song
that Prince ever did.
I want to know every
song that's on an album.
I want to know if we have
number of records sold
I want to aggregate all of
the records sold for Prince
over a period of time.
I can co-locate the index
with the physical data
to further increase performance
by interleaving that table
in the parent table.
So I can say create index
songs by singer album
songs on this table, provide
the columns that I want,
and interleave it in tables.
So now when I do that
query there is no chance
that my index, which is just
a normal table in Spanner,
doesn't get located
on another node.
So the way to think about this
is if I build a secondary index
and I don't tell Cloud Spanner
that it's interleave, what
can happen is the primary
table could be on one node
and the index table
could be on another node.
And now every time I want to
update the primary table I have
to coordinate between the two of
them and do a two phase commit.
Similarly if I want to
do a consistent read
I have to access both
nodes to get the data.
But if I tell Cloud Spanner
that this data is related
by interleaving it, then I
can always go to a single node
and I don't have to
incur the overhead
of going to multiple nodes.
Let's talk about
some anti-patterns.
So I talked a little
bit about this earlier,
but I wanted to reiterate
the point because it's
a common problem that we see.
As you're loading data
into Cloud Spanner
there's a natural inclination
to use timestamps or values that
will incrementally increase
as you go through the system.
And what happens here is
because you're constantly
adding keys that
are further along
you're forcing all of the writes
onto a single Cloud Spanner
server.
And so what happens
is that you can hot
spot the server
because you're always
trying to add another value
at the end of the row.
If you can add a shard ID--
either by taking a couple
of values off the hash
or just adding a random shard--
what that allows us to do--
and then putting that in
the primary key first--
what that allows us to do is
to evenly distribute the writes
across all the Spanner servers.
So by giving us a
more diverse key space
you allow us to better shard
the data across the nodes
and that allows us to more
effectively write data
into the system.
One of the things that's
in here is split points.
So we do our very
best never to split
between primary
keys and the root
table, which is the first table
at the top of the interleave.
And so the more
values you give us
of primary keys at the
root table the more places
we have to put splits.
And because you've told us that
this data isn't interleaved
we know that we can split
it up across multiple nodes
and that will be fine.
If you do interleave
it then we know that we
need to keep it together.
And that gives us,
again, a better hint
of how to logically lay out
your data in the database.
And so where this is most
important is data loading.
So one of the challenges
is making sure
that you load in your
data in an efficient way.
So one is partition your
data by primary key.
So using the best
practices we talked about
either invert your
timestamps or put a hash
or create a shard ID in
front of your timestamps
or moving the timestamp to the
second or third primary key
is a way to make sure that
we can partition your data
efficiently and load your
data the most efficient way.
We also recommend that
you batch your commits
into 1 to 5 megabyte
mutations at a time
so you can do multiple writes
in a single transaction.
We recommend about
1 to 5 megabytes
of data on each transaction.
And the last thing is create
your table and your schema,
load your data, and
then add your indexes.
It's much faster
to load your data
and then allow us to back
fill a secondary index than it
is for us to do multiple
writes on every insert
by making sure that
we've inserted data
into the primary table and
the index on every write.
So always add your
indexes at the end
if you're doing a
large data load job.
As you saw in the keynote
demo that we did today
we did an 80 terabyte database
of ticket information.
And as we were
loading the data, we
were able to dramatically
increase the load time
by batching up the
mutations and making sure
that we had a very
diverse key space.
And it really does
impact your ability
to load data into the
system if you break
any of these best practices.
All right.
Query optimization.
So you have all the basic
pieces of schema designed,
you understand what
the gotchas are,
so now you can start to
look at your queries.
So first of all Cloud SQL speaks
SQL for its schema definition
and for its querying.
When you're doing mutations
we provide a separate API
for doing mutations so that
you can be more explicit to us
about what you want us
to do with your data.
But as you do your queries
there's a number of ways
that you can have
slow queries or want
to speed up your queries.
So the first one is
missing an index.
So I want to select last name
first name from singers where
the last name equals Smith.
Now the issue here is that I'm
not searching on index data.
So I'm doing a full table scan.
So if I want to avoid doing
that I can create an index
singers by last name on
singers and index last name.
So this will allow me to more
efficiently query the table
and pull back that information.
Now I can actually
make this faster.
If I go ahead and do
this first query--
select last name first name
where last name equals Smith--
I will find the row
based on last name
but I still have to go
back to the primary table
to get the first name.
So I still have to join
back to the primary table
after I find the key.
So the way that you can
optimize this in Cloud Spanner
is using the storing function.
So you can say
create index singers
by last name on singer's
last name storing first name.
So what I've done is I've
added additional information
to the index so that
I can retrieve data
by directly reading
the index table
and never having to go
back to the primary table.
So again, another way
to alleviate the need
to go back and do effectively a
join back to the primary table.
Missing indexes for
ordered results.
So if you were doing
lots of selects
and you are doing
order by you want
to make sure that you
have an index that's
properly built for that.
So if you're saying select
first name last name
from singers order by last
name first name descending,
then you want to make sure
that you have created an index.
So singers by last
name on singer's
last name first
name and descending.
And the way that you
figure all this out we
very quickly showed
in the keynote
today how to look
at your queries.
And so when you run a
query in the Cloud console
there's a button there
that says explain query
and it will show you what we're
actually doing in the query.
And so these things will
become apparent to you
as you look at the query plan
to understand whether or not
you're effectively
using your indexes.
So what if I'm not
using my indexes?
Or what if I'm trying to do
different kinds of joins?
So a number of people
have come up to me today
at the Spanner booth and
said do you support joins?
And I say yes.
And they say which joins?
And so we do support
a number of joins.
So inter, cross, full,
left and write we do--
these are all again
additional vectors for you
to help optimize how
you're querying your data--
but we do provide a
number of options for you
that you would expect
from a traditional RDBMS.
The other thing that we
do is join directives.
So we often talk about
how Cloud Spanner uses
ANSI SQL 2011 with extensions.
The two main extensions that
we have are interleave--
so for interleave tables--
and our annotations.
And one of the most
common annotations
is a join directive.
So you can see in this first
query select star from singers
join and then this
at bracket annotation
is what we use across SQL in
Spanner to do annotations.
Instead of doing a
SQL keyword for this
we wanted to have a single
semantic for doing these hints,
not just for joins
but across the data.
And so this is the
annotation extension
that we've added to SQL.
One of the things that's
interesting about Spanner
and is different than
a traditional RDBMS
is that Spanner
doesn't try to assume
too much about your data.
It doesn't try to figure
out the best possible way
to run your query.
We have a query optimizer and if
there's an obvious index for us
to use then we'll use it.
But in many scenarios
Spanner will not
choose to use the index that
you might have intended.
And so Spanner is designed to
be very explicit about what
you want to do.
And so one of these is indexes.
So when you run this query if
you look on the query explain
and you notice that you aren't
hitting your join then what you
can do is use the second query.
So select singer first
name last name singer
info from singers at
force index equals
and you can tell us the index.
So if you look at your
query explain plan
and you realize that you
aren't hitting the index
you can add this
annotation to your join
to force the query
to use your index.
And the last one is we also
have additional hash join types.
So here we've got a hash join.
There are loop joins as well.
And all of this is in
the SQL documentation.
But we do provide all of these
as ways for you to optimize.
Again, Cloud Spanner the
only knob you get is nodes.
So all of these tools
that we have in the schema
and in the querier are your
tools to optimize your queries
and optimize your performance.
All write, with that I'm going
to bring up Peter Bakkum.
Enough of the information
about Spanner.
I'm sure all of you want to
get some practical information
about what it really
means to use Spanner,
so I bring up Peter.
PETER BAKKUM: Hey
everybody, I'm Peter.
I work on a platform
at Quizlet and I'm
going to be talking to
you today about what
it's like to use a
Spanner from a customer's
perspective and some of
the results of our testing.
We were really, really
fortunate to get early access
to a Spanner and we've been
playing around with it.
So my goal here is to give you
a really good picture of what
we've learned and hopefully
come away from this talk
with a better idea
of how you might
use Spanner yourself
for your own workloads.
As I said, we've been
testing for a while.
I'm going to show you
some of the test results.
We hope to run Spanner
in production for one
of our tables very, very soon.
And we'll have more
information then.
But I'm going to give you
a complete picture of what
we know.
So I want to start by giving you
just a brief introduction to us
at Quizlet.
Quizlet is an edtech company.
We're a study tool.
The product is you plug
in terms and definitions
and it gives you different
ways to study them.
So you can think of it as
like a digital flashcard,
that kind of thing.
Quizlet we've been really lucky
to have strong organic growth
and so Quizlet over time has
grown into a top 25 website
in the US.
We have about 25
million users a month
and a bunch of different
study modes, web clients,
mobile native
clients, et cetera.
Our growth curve over
time has looked like this.
As I said, we've had really
strong organic growth
and this is an interesting
challenge for databases
for several reasons.
So one is that you'll
note is that it's
very, very seasonal, right?
It turns out no one really
studies in the summer.
So we get this big
drop in the summer.
It's pretty quiet.
And then around
August, September
we hit back to school.
And so there we get
this big, big rush.
And as we go up that's also
where a lot of our growth hits.
So in the summer we have
to do is preparation.
We need to prepare
for this traffic
that we've never
really seen before.
So very, very seasonal
but also the traffic
is gradually increasing.
It's always going up.
And so what this
means is that we've
had to continually
re-architect and re-figure out
how to run our application.
Quizlet runs MySQL.
Like many applications,
we started just
with a simple web
app using MySQL.
And over time we've had to
optimize this and grow this
into a more complex
architecture.
Our architecture now looks
a little bit like this.
So let me explain
this a little bit.
We started with just
a simple database.
We added replicas
so that you could
fail-over from the master to a
replica if you needed to you.
Can also swap back and
forth for maintenance.
We've added replica for backups.
And then one of the
ways we've scaled
is by taking some of our
tables and splitting them out
into their own pods of
maters and replicas.
So this is basically
vertical sharding, right?
We've taken a table, we're
running it separately,
and we scale up this way.
So you know this has grown.
We have about eight pods of
this in production write now.
You can see on this
diagram some of the pods
have multiple replicas.
We also have a tier of
caching to help scale.
So I think this is a fairly
standard architecture
and I'm sure that many
people in this room
have something similar, maybe
even with a greater scale.
Several problems with this.
So one is just complexity.
There's a lot of lines up here.
It's a complex architecture,
we need to run it,
we need to handle replication,
backups, et cetera fail-overs
et cetera.
So you know maintenance
costs, difficulty.
But the other problem is
just scalability, right?
So we haven't done any
horizontal sharding.
This means that a
single table is only
running accepting writes at
most on a single machine.
So this is a pretty fundamental
barrier for us, right?
We can only handle
so many writes
on a single machine this means
we're limited in how big we
can let a table grow.
So what's the next phase?
This is really, really
critical for Quizlet.
This is the primary datastore
so everything depends on this.
And in fact, if
this goes down we
literally we have students
complaining to us,
we have people
tweeting at us, people
in classrooms come to a halt.
This is what this looks like.
So if Quizlet's database goes
down we get tweets like this.
This is literally a
classroom of students.
It's hard to see but
they're all holding up
iPads that say Quizlet
is down on them.
And so I show this just
to underline the point
that database stability and
scalability is like really,
really critical for us.
It's a study product,
it's very high engagement
when you use it, and so
it's really important
that the database be
stable in performance
and it grows over time.
So we want to
solve this problem.
We've been examining
Spanner to do that.
And I want to talk to you next
about how we looked at this
and how we evaluated
whether Spanner would be
a good match for this workload.
So how did do we do this?
Well, the first thing we did
is we picked a table that we
were having trouble scaling.
So first table we picked
was called the Terms table.
It's about 700 gigabytes
6 billion rows.
And this is the core
content of Quizlet
so it's a really important
table for us SQL to scale.
Receives it's about
70% reads 30% writes.
So fairly significant
right load.
So we took this
table, we observed
how it looked in production.
So the queries coming in,
did a capture of those.
Looked in-depth at the
patterns et cetera.
And then we created a synthetic
workload based on that capture.
So what I mean by that
is we wrote a script
to generate queries
in a similar pattern
as the captured queries.
So same ratio of
reads and writes,
same query patterns, same
locality of IDs et cetera
as close as we can make it look.
So we had this
synthetic workload
and then were able to play
this against both Spanner
in our test environment and
against a separate test MySQL.
And this is interesting
because it gives us
a really clean environment for
comparing these two systems
and doing results.
So let me caveat this by saying
this is obviously very, very
specific to our use case and
the results you are going to see
are totally totally
specific to your workload
and may look different
in other cases.
But I want to show you what
this looks like for us.
First question I have is how
do these databases scale?
So how did we answer this?
Well what we've done is we've
taken our synthetic workload,
we've played against
both systems,
and we've observed query latency
as we changed the throughput.
So x-axis here is throughput
y-axis is latency.
As you can see MySQL latency
initially lower than Spanner.
So this is around 1 millisecond
during normal conditions.
We then as you can expect you
eventually hit your performance
ceiling and so we hit a
threshold at which we really
can't handle more queries.
We see a spike in
latency for MySQL here.
Spanner we have a
higher base latency
and obviously you also cap
out at a certain point.
But the key point here is
it's really, really easy
to just change the
number of nodes
and scale the Spanner cluster
and move your performance
ceiling higher.
So this is the
whole point right?
This is why this is
a powerful system.
So this is median latency.
And the other thing we want
you to look at is tail latency.
So what you're looking at here
is 99th percentile latency
on this workload that we ran.
So again we're comparing
these two systems
where we're running
Spanner at different sizes.
And you can see as you approach
your thresholds tail latency
goes up in this curve, right?
An interesting
thing here also is
that the Spanner tail latency
act-- or the MySQL tail latency
is actually worse than Spanner
for the low query thresholds.
So again this is
totally specific to us
and specific to the MySQL
instance we were running,
but our goal here was to test
the scalability of Spanner
and how a synthetic workload
would look on the two systems.
And I think it was a
successful strategy.
So I want to dig
a little bit more
into this latency
because I think
it's really important if you're
using Spanner and implementing
it to an application.
So what I'm going
to show you now
is a histogram of Spanner
latency in this workload.
So this is Spanner latency
for one of the easier queries
we were running.
The axis is buckets of latency
and the y-axis is count.
So this query on Spanner we saw
5 milliseconds median latency.
And this is the curve we saw.
So we see an initial
jump in the curve
and then we see a
longer tail latency.
But as I noted before, the
long tail is fairly thin.
So to us Spanner was
surprisingly consistent
in its performance.
So this is great.
We know about the latency.
We know a little bit
of a scalability.
I want to talk more about what
are the implications of Spanner
for application?
And one of the other things
we want to know about--
well, there's several things.
So one as I noted with Spanner
compared to MySQL just running
on a vanilla VM
probably your base
latency is going to be
a little bit higher.
You tail latency is
probably going to be lower.
For us a higher
base latency needs
we need to be more
thoughtful about how
we use it in the application.
So asynchronous queries become
a little more important.
And the other thing is that
it's very, very scalable.
So again, this is the thing
we really like about Spanner.
This is the power.
That we can just change
the number of nodes
and adjust the performance
ceiling of the database.
So what this means is that for
your application auto scaling
becomes really, really simple.
You're basically just
changing a variable.
The other thing we noted--
Spanner is a distributed system.
As you may know, it partitions
your data into splits.
And this has implications
on your schema,
on your IDs, et cetera
as Don mentioned.
The other interesting
thing we observed--
so as we were running
the synthetic workload
we ran it on both systems.
Both, as you can
imagine, you initially
start sending the queries
you see warming, right?
Both systems warm up.
You see the initial spike and
then they're a bit flatter.
Cloud Spanner interestingly
also optimizes
the splits and so over time,
we saw a more gradual warming
on Spanner.
So as we ran a
certain cluster size
the latency would actually
get better over time.
So we have a good idea now
of Spanner performance,
scalability, some
of the implications
of integrating with our app.
And I want to talk
a little bit more
about what this
looks like for us.
In other words, how
we integrate it.
So several things here.
First thing is we need
a way to talk to Spanner
so we need to pick a client.
Quizlet was originally
written in PHP.
We now run on HHVM, which
is Facebook's PHP compiler.
And our code is a
mix of PHP and Hack.
PHP is the favorite
language of few people.
And so we've optimized and
we really like HHVM and Hack
and it's been a good way to
carry our application forward.
So there's not yet
a Spanner PHP client
though I understand
one is coming soon.
So initial options for
the client are one.
There's the REST API--
this is just totally
generic sending HTTP
and getting responses back.
Two-- one of the things that
I really like about Spanner
is that it sits behind
a gRCP interface.
So because it's
gRPC the interface
is defined totally
programmatically
and it's actually possible
to generate clients
in any language
that gRPC supports.
So we've actually use
both of these strategies
for our application.
Next thing for us is how
do we take our application
and actually create queries to
send to Spanner and send them?
So like many applications
we use an ORM.
Ours is custom to us.
I put an example query here.
The point is that the
application you're composing
a query using this
fluent interface,
you're setting some parameters,
maybe some query predicates,
et cetera.
Then you're going
and generating SQL.
So integration for us looks
like taking this interface
and reimplementing the back
end specifically for Spanner.
So the SQL dialect is
a little bit different
than MySQL and Spanner
doesn't offer DML statements.
So that's a little
bit different.
But in general
it's very similar.
And this is the
whole point, right?
We want something
relational we can move to.
So we've taken
this ORM interface
and we've reimplemented it for
Spanner and so within our app
we're now able to communicate
with both systems using
the same fluent interface.
This is our strategy
for handling this.
So I want to talk a little bit
more about schema for our case.
As Dom, mentioned there's some
definite schema implications
for Spanner.
You know the nice part is
that much of our schema maps
directly over.
Again, this is the whole point.
We want to move
to a system where
we have the relational model,
our data types carry over,
our queries carry over,
and it's more scalable.
So most things
map directly over.
There's a few implications
for the ID format.
I'm going to dive into that.
And then the other
important thing to remember
is just you want your schema
to be thoughtful around data
locality.
So you want to use your schema
to limit the number of queries
that touch multiple splits.
In other words, that touch a
bunch of areas of your data.
And I'll show you
how we do this.
So I'm going to show
you our schema on MySQL
and then our schema on Spanner.
There's a lot of details.
I'm going to highlight the
important parts of this.
It's mostly pretty
similar, right?
We've taken our columns,
we've mapped them over,
we've mapped them into
the Spanner's data types.
The things I'm going to
call out here are one--
we've added new ID columns.
So we've added columns
specific to Spanner's ID.
Sorry, specific to Spanner's
favorable primary key
characteristics.
We've changed the primary key.
And we've intentionally
used a primary key
that gives us a locality
on that column Spanner ID.
So the Spanner ID
column there's locality
within the Spanner set ID.
And we've designed the
primary key that way.
We've also leveraged
a secondary index here
and so we're creating that
in the scheme as well.
So let me explain
a little bit more
about how we're handling IDs.
So, as Don mentioned,
Spanner does not
have auto incrementing IDs and
even if it did you probably
wouldn't want to use them.
The reason is that you want
to distribute your writes
over multiple splits
and so it's much more
favorable to use something
with a lot of entropy
in the first few bits.
So there's different
ways to slice this.
Our choice was v4 uuid
and this is basically
just randomly generated uuid.
There's other uuid formats v1
that aren't favorable for this
and the reason is that they
can include a time component
in the very beginning
so you're not even
redistributing your rights.
So we don't store any
meaning in the IDs.
So we're just using
randomly generated IDs.
The other interesting
thing in our case
is that backwards
compatibility with previous IDs
is very important to us.
So as I mentioned, Quizlet
has native mobile clients.
All these native
mobile clients they
depend on a certain
version of the API.
They access models with
certain assumptions
like they have integer IDs.
And they actually
cache data as well.
So they're storing
data and saving them.
And so migrating to a new system
means supporting those clients
because they're mobile clients
we can't just upgrade them
all immediately, right?
They're out there in the wild.
So we very explicitly
left in our previous IDs
and we have a secondary index
in our schema for those IDs.
This is a little bit--
this is a diagram of
what this looks like.
We have multiple
versions of our API.
We've planned a new version
to support a new ID scheme
and we're going to be migrating
mobile clients over to this
as we go.
One more thing I want
to talk about and that's
how we move data into Spanner.
So, as I mentioned, uptime
is very important to us.
Stability is important to us.
And so we can't just shut
the site down for hours
as we prepare the new
database and copy data in.
So we want to be able to
transition over, flip a switch,
and have it be done.
So the way we think about
this is replicating data
by establishing writes
to both systems.
So we take our application,
we're using MySQL,
we're reading and
writing for MySQL,
MySQL is a source of truth.
We're also duplicating
writes to Spanner.
So we send writes there as well.
That means mutations to our
models go to both systems.
While that's
happening we then run
a copy client in the
background that copies
data over into Spanner
and eventually you
end up with a very
consistent data set.
This is a little tricky
because only one system can
be the source of truth, right?
Only one system can
be the source of truth
and so if a write
fails for the other one
you need to know that.
You then have a
data inconsistency.
So for us this just means
tracking those failed writes
and ensuring that both
systems are consistent.
So the whole point of this
is to transition over easily,
so you begin writing
in both systems,
you do the copy
in the background,
you reach a point where they're
similar, you stop writes,
and then you can just flip
over to the new system.
This is our plan for switching
over a table to Spanner.
So that's all I've prepared.
Thanks for listening.
I hope this was useful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]